hello everyone happy Wednesday welcome
to gratitude journal live stream number
8 it's amazing to be back here with you
I see a number of people already in the
live chat right to give some shoutouts
to quick recap of why we do this is it's
important to celebrate what you're
grateful for every day makes you happy a
person makes you happy entrepreneur
helps you get through the down times the
hatred the anger the depression the
failures the losses it's really hard to
be negative and grateful at the same
time I think it's a practice that I've
got a lot of value from and bring it to
my team and I brought it to you guys as
well two most important things that are
part of it is one that its daily it's
got to be daily it's every single day
you know just like motivation its daily
just like you brush your teeth its daily
it's not something you do once a week
you need to be grateful daily for the
things to really appreciate them in your
life and the second thing is it's super
important that you actually feel it and
I mention this every day but it's super
important it's not just listing off
something that you're grateful for it
it's actually trying to put yourself in
the moment of appreciating really truly
deeply meaningfully appreciating that
thing that you have in your life that
you're grateful for today because
otherwise it's not really a useful
exercise for you if you really want to
get through those negative times in your
life or negative times that you might be
facing today it's important that you're
actually putting yourself you're
changing your emotional state by
thinking of what your repo for so the
way this works is I will share three
things at iron group before I'm excited
to read out some of the ones that you
guys are grateful for today in the chat
to leave them there and for those you
guys watching the replay of this make
sure to leave it down in the comments
below so that you guys can benefit from
as well so for me I'm grateful that it's
it's Wednesday and it's video day
Wednesday is one of my favorite days of
the week I'm going to record a video
after this with Rishi cap do some League
of Legends business Q&A but after that
I'm going to head to the trauma that's
also studio and record my videos for you
guys for the week
and I love it because it's feeling like
this is this is a big part of my
contribution you know the messages that
I deliver today are going to be
important they're gonna be seen by
millions of people and I take that with
this there's a burden of responsibility
there but also you know I know that
people spend time some people every
single day watching my videos and and I
want to deliver for them so I'm bringing
that energy into video there today and
i'm always super painful for wednesday
just one of your days of the week uh I'm
grateful for my speaking mentors there's
been a number of people who who I've met
personally and just people who have who
are aspirational mentors that have
helped me along the way to help me be a
better speaker I think of my agent Steve
and my my coach Jani both really helped
me a lot when I was in the early days of
my youtube channel to make me better on
the aspirational side I think of Les
Brown and Tony Robbins those two guys
have inspired me a lot with the way that
they speak in fact every morning I do
work out just before this just before
you regret is adjourned I do a workout
for 20 minutes in grab a 10-minute
shower and usually i watch videos where
I'm learning something but on Wednesdays
it's always listening to some less brown
stuff he has a coaching program and I
bought that and I go through that every
Wednesday morning because it's video day
because I gotta I gotta I gotta bring it
when i get to try to myself since a film
and so super grateful that these people
are in my life whether you know i can
pick up a phone call them or just turn
on a video listen to them really i've
seen me the change in me I've seen the
change in the product that i've created
know the videos that come out and so
really beautiful for that and the third
thing you know I'm really grateful that
I can control my own schedule uh I mean
that's one of the luxuries of being an
entrepreneur and yes you have to respond
to customers and you know deal with
suppliers and all that stuff but at the
end of the day
to create my own schedule and for the
most part i'm a really schedule focused
and oriented guy you know from this time
at this time I do this and from this
time that this time to do that you know
we do the gratitude journal stream 9
a.m. every weekday sometimes know what
I'm when I'm in the flow when I'm
feeling something different I just I go
with it and I've learned to trust that
instinct to just go with it and just
trust that magic is going to happen and
that good stuff will happen by breaking
the schedule that happens too many times
and I might have to change the schedule
because you know doesn't fit anymore but
yesterday was one of those days where I
finished a little bit early and I had
something else aside but I didn't do it
I did something else that I just was
interested in and it led to some
interesting results so being able to
control my own schedule I know if I if I
didn't if I was you know working on a
job and I had to be here from this time
to this time and I had no control I'd be
I'd be pretty would be pretty bad
employee it'd be pretty frustrated so
I'm super grateful that I chose this
path of entrepreneurship and get to even
within that path design the business
that's meant to be a no crisis business
where I'm not always just reacting the
things on the spot but actually planning
with intention and create my own
schedule so that's it that's what I'm
grateful for super excited I want to
read off what you guys are good before
get some shout out to the people in the
live stream and the four minutes that we
have left first up J reyez google for
grateful for voice language and
self-expression grateful for Tony
Robbins that's there we go we got
back-to-back Tony Robbins and the
shoulders of giants we all stand on
grateful for birthday love presents
celebrations we prefer internet cafes to
help me when I need solid internet in a
pinch I feel you there Jay I actually
did that once with a Weber hang out when
I was in LA it crashed on me and I had
to come back to trauma so let's do this
again and I made sure I went to internet
cafe and Jay helped me with that a lot
because I didn't want to risk you know
my internet going down again Zeno oh the
body part body part of the day number
one mine
nose and tongue for making it possible
for me to taste good food good call bad
food as well but let's stay positive
number two video games movies and music
for allowing me to practice my escapism
something sometimes you just need to do
sometimes you just need that will I do
number three the seemingly unlimited an
endless love and support from believe
nation I as fist bump right there right
back at you say no I'm feeling it what
else we got Rishi cup is here cup of
happy but vigas back hello yessir
grateful I slept 12 hours today yessir
that's a long sleep bro I hope you're
well rested and ready to go off and
tackle the world grateful for 12 hours
celebrity artist good morning everyone
good morning celebrity artist I bandhan
I'm in school we're all in school we're
all in school we're in believe nation
school right now yessir had to clarify
12 12 hours and 27 minutes that's that's
that's some deep sleep man that is some
deep sleep I don't remember the last
time I slept 12 hours shaundi grateful
for having my little sister she doesn't
understand half the things I tell her
but I feel relieved and satisfied after
venting everything out to her don't know
if the sisters the one you want a vent
everything to but that I'm I'm feeling
it I I have a little sister and an older
sister and I'm I'm grouper for both of
them as well Jairaj good for his little
sister to father zoo TV how do you know
it's real you touch it mahuva I'm
grateful to evan is so awesome I'm
grateful you're so awesome bro thank you
for that comment your believe nation and
you have to believe that sleep is cool I
listen I love sleep phul for good
night's sleep go back in the journal a
couple days ago I was grateful for a
good night's sleep wasn't 12 hours what
is it good night's sleep Jackie good
morning I'm grateful for my supportive
family this broadcast in the community I
love at Jackie welcome aboard father's
new TV I'm grateful that I'm alive I'm
gonna live man and healthy
I love it welcome welcome aboard man I'm
IP Scheck hashtag believe thank you for
all your wonderful words of wisdom thank
you for joining in man I appreciate it
Muhammad can I speaking Indonesian
language because my english is bad you
can do whatever you want man I mean I
understood that so you're which isn't
that bad don't lock yourself I can't
promise you that I understand indonesian
but you wrote i actually guarantee that
i won't understand what you ready but
it's more important is that you get that
expression out that you feel the words
that you write so whatever language you
want to use pictures drawings your local
language put it in there Evan you make
me smile the sessions make me smile even
when I don't feel good I force myself to
think of the good things around and I
never fail to notice a few every time
honestly that's the point right like no
matter how about a day you're having no
matter what crap is happening in this
entrepreneurs we face a lot of downs a
lot of negatives trying to build our
thing up just being forced to think
about the things that are around you
that are positive that you are great
before that you do have a good life can
really make a big difference guys were
nine ten thank you so much for the shot
of gratitude here in the morning if you
want to keep on with the live streaming
we're going to head over to my twitch
channel and do a business Q&A with Rishi
and Jay rise and again for those of you
watching after if you didn't get your
chance to get shouted here leave it in
the comments below three things you get
before today carry that with you for the
rest of the day and I will see you again
tomorrow continue to believe or whatever
your one where it is have a great day
guys